[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
all right you guys should be able to
hear us
uh fair warning uh I'm still new to
making this new format
uh so guys just bear with me man bear
with me
I gotta I gotta do it live because for
some reason OBS it doesn't like it
doesn't show you I don't know why
uh
all right we're live though by the way
oh hello everyone how are you
there's got to be a a simpler way of
doing this now I'm just tweeting it out
and I'm
sending it to friends and family you
know what's funny because this is so new
I didn't even know what to name this I
was I'm just going to name it we love
everything
it's like because until like we get kind
of understanding what we want the show
to be really yeah yeah
um
all right you guys you should be able to
see us relatively okay uh we are having
this rehab Vamp just a little bit
uh you guys just have to bear with us
until we finish it
um but what's going on you guys this is
this is the uh
r r with the Lords you know we we we
have a couple topics not a whole lot
because right now you know TV and movies
they're a little bit uh down in terms of
everything but they're gonna pick up
here real soon real fast but the good
thing about this king is like we can we
can iron out the way we want the show to
be before the real stuff starts popping
off if you hold up say yeah definitely
because it actually it looks crazy but
uh even so
my behind has found stuff to look at
so so I guess first thing we could talk
about is uh
it is the homework man we can talk about
the homework first so how'd you what
what all did you watch with Attack on
Titan so two episodes
two episodes and you told me it gets
better after the third episode so the
first two episodes first of all I was
mad as hell that there's a bunch of butt
naked Giants outside the wall right but
they don't know why they're locked
inside there or corralled like cattle
and this this one little kid he he
he wants them to put respect on the name
of the military but he sees the military
as not even working hard enough to get
the accolades that they get and get the
praise that they get
and then he's seen them have to go to
war
and then he seen his mom's die when the
when when the Giants started coming over
the gate and coming through the walls
it's like uh uh and and these these
Giants just want to taste a human flesh
they just want to eat human so it's more
like they go out they it's just like
cattle like they have them around in
this world they build build this wall
they think they're safe they're not safe
at all and they just continue to breed
and multiply and then the Giants come in
dwiddle the numbers eat them up and then
leave
because they went out there to go kill
one giant and that giant killed and
decimated half the squad and they didn't
even kill that giant so I don't know man
um it's interesting stuff right now is
I'm still lukewarm on the series on
Attack on Titan but
I I'm still gonna give it a chance
here's the thing
Attack on Titan is one of those shows
where they introduce you to a lore and
then they're like
about
10 15 20 episodes in there like oh we
lied and then like 1050s episodes oh we
lied again
and it's like 10 50 oh you think you
know the world we lied again like it's
just constantly like reevaluating like
what you think is going on
like lost lost did that a lot yeah
remember that like I got so pissed off
with loss when when they just woke up on
the island they were stranded and we had
no idea what the hell was going on then
it was uh the government abduction or
was it aliens or was it something else
I I fell off of the series
but it's very early on it does uh do a
good job after here's the thing like you
right now you're you're in the initial
like you're in the walls the wall more
uh Maria uh I can't remember the three
walls if someone in the chat I know
you've seen I put the three walls in the
chat uh but you're establishing the laws
of the walls and you know there's they
feel safe Behind the Walls have you been
introduced into the scouts yet
one of those dudes that go out to go
outside the walls yeah yeah the dudes
the machines on them with the blades and
stuff
yeah so you're being established
the laws of that area because for the
most part for like the next I would say
three or four episodes it's going to be
primarily in that second wall because at
the beginning
uh the the end yeah Rose that's right I
can't remember which one but at the
beginning the the first episode you saw
you saw the Colossal Titan destroy the
inner uh the outer wall the I think it
was Maria and Rose and so pretty much
forced all that population and that
whole wall to go to the second wall and
keep in mind the rich people live in the
middle
like the rich rich people uh and so
obviously he's a commoners right now
from from what I'm saying like they're
they're peasants so yeah and they they
don't want the rich folks don't want
the poor folks to live in that wall with
them of course not yeah because there's
because obviously you know you get you
get a sinner uh a center area and when
you keep expanding the room gets a lot
more so the second the center wall is
the smallest by far the second law is is
a little bit bigger than the third wall
is by far the most because they have the
most space between them uh so every time
they lose one of those walls it forces
like huge starvation because they
they've lost all that access to the
farmlands that they would have so it's
it's it's a really in-depth thing and um
I'm feeling that
you get a couple more episodes you have
a different tone all right well you know
I'm basing it off of my greatest cartoon
of all time anime of all time uh is uh
Naruto I I just you know love the
character love the storyline I love the
fact that on fortnite I got it shout out
to Monkey I was racing home to get to
play with him on fortnite but uh you
know RNR with the Lord's first and then
uh get a chance to hang out with the
monster and uh my my homework for you
next week get up to episode six and then
okay well well I am is just you know
Thanksgiving we got people fly and then
he only remembers all this stuff it's
crazy it's a crazy week normally I don't
do anything on Tuesdays and here I am
stuck in the Bronx stuck in the Book of
Eli
is that where that movie's took in place
at no no no I just call it the um it's
like Fallout it's like
you know I'm gonna take you to the Bronx
when you come back to New York so you
can see exactly what Fallout looks like
live like since you since you like fall
out I want to take Maddie to the Bronx
and just drop him in the middle of the
Bronx and because since he like fall out
so much
I ain't trying to do that man you ain't
doing that to me see uh I like living
and no no you're not gonna die no it's
not that I'm gonna die it's just I'm
gonna feel mad intimidated everywhere I
go because I don't know that area I
don't know what's going on I've heard
stories so that that you got that on top
of it too I've seen power so
yeah yeah yeah definitely look at Eli
that's the Bronx is the Book of Eli so
so I I I did watch your your movie last
week
this week you know what's funny
there is a show that just had a new
season called The Barbarians on Netflix
right and I thought that's what you
wanted me to watch no I've watched three
episodes of that
how was it for you
I was just like well I gotta finish it
like I thought you wanted me because
because it was new so that's right
because you know how like Netflix has
that new icon that pops up on there I
thought that's what you wanted me to
watch so I watched three epic and I'm
not saying the show's bad it's not bad
but I will say there's other stuff you
guys can watch like I like Avalon five
I'm watching Avalon 5 on HBO Max I think
it's actually the funniest thing that's
on because I like space drama so it this
is space drama comedy and then I like
the the
um the actor that played house on on the
show House I like him as an actor and
he's absolutely hilarious in his role as
a captain there's so much stuff that's
going on on Avalon 5. if anybody get a
chance to watch it it is probably one of
the funniest just space drama uh uh
comedy shows that you can watch you will
have a great time watching it it's funny
it's entertaining and uh it's it gives
you a sense it's so much going on that
there's not a time for you to not be
entertained somebody has something going
on so it's that's dope stuff but let's
get to the main event we don't want a
whole of people let's talk about this
yeah Barbarian
all right first off I'm watching I think
it's going to be like some stalkers kind
of movie yeah you know it's going to be
a movie that
I cringe because it's a white dude doing
it first off second off I'm like man do
we really need more stories about like
stalker as white men because because it
gets it like that that's the way they
love to go with that uh spoiler alert in
the middle
the the title of the movie in the middle
I feel you
yeah let's let's let's let's let's you
want me to send it to you oh yeah I mean
we we can do that that's fine but how am
I gonna have the title In The Middle
With The spoiler as well well either one
you know I mean
you know barbarians we we are just to
clarify guys
we are working on changing this format
completely like I want to put a spoiler
thing somewhere that glows when we're
spoiling because I want to use the
middle part for actual coverage instead
of uh you know what's being used for uh
yeah so there's the spoiler
uh it's
this movie I would say it's a good movie
well it's definitely like a b-rated
movie like
um I was you know when I got okay the
beginning
so pretty much what happens they make
you think it's like some stalker thing
that make this dude mad weird like like
completely giving weird Vibes like I'm
not even the chick but you're not
setting it up hold up hold up let's set
it up how the movie starts okay so the
movie stars uh this this individual she
gets out and she gets an Airbnb test
that's test so Tess gets out she gets an
Airbnb uh she tried uh first off what's
funny is they kind of make you think
that she got the wrong Airbnb because
she messed up the password at the
beginning so she realizes she messed up
the password and she gets she puts the
right password and I don't know if any
of you that does Airbnb in the chat but
usually they have like some some
mechanism that lets you get in the house
like you know uh they'll have on the
door itself they'll have where you have
to put a code in or something but this
is one of those things where it was the
the mailbox
had a mechanism where you could get the
key out of the mailbox so she opens it
and there's there's nothing there so she
calls uh apparently the people who did
this are idiots and they double booked
to be Airbnb and there's a gentleman
that is currently in the house so he
invites her in and keep in mind this
dude is being weird mad weird the entire
time yes but all right we gotta say who
the guy is that's the guy who played it
so you already know normally without the
makeup he looks crazy go oh he's played
it yeah that's the dude who plays it you
don't notice his eye his eye goes to the
left like a Frenchie but so pretty much
how how they make you
played out to be is this dude it kind of
making you seem like it's a stalkers
kind of thing and she's going to stay
there you know what's funny when she
woke up in the middle of the night
because he ended up giving her her
bedroom and the door was open so and he
claimed he didn't do it he was like on
the couch like spazzing out so what was
funny is I'm thinking she about to go to
bed in the movie about to start you know
what I'm saying but she wakes up and
it's in the daytime like oh I didn't
expect that like because because the
movie's not about a stalker look
assistant so the dude leaves that she
leaves and she does that interview and
and when she was like yo I I I'm Airbnb
in here the interview is like no girl
you got to leave there like no you you
ain't doing that like because because it
happens in Detroit Michigan right so all
right so let me let me give y'all a
little bit of context okay so I added
got up to the next the following day
right so
that night when she pulls in it's heavy
rain so she doesn't see the neighborhood
as she's getting in it's just to be
honest it's like really dark too like I
don't think she saw it that well either
exactly so you know what it felt like to
me it felt like when we went to Boston
when we went to Pax
so she coming in and she tries to get in
and she has to like the wrong passcode
like addict said to to open the door so
Tess is she she goes and she gets the
password and she gets it right and then
the Box opens up so the Box opens up but
there's no key inside so she turns
around automatically just like everybody
would do uh call Airbnb yo uh there's no
key here I'm here I paid my money blah
blah blah but she gets an answering
service nobody picks up and she goes
like we'll get back to this answering
service because these people are crazy
we'll get back to that in a second yeah
this is crazy so the dude opens the door
because he hears somebody outside
outside fumbling with you know the front
of the door you know you and he's in the
house by himself in this weird
neighborhood
and the dude opens the door so you
automatically assume
that it's you know
a little bit older middle-aged white
dude uh and we're we're thinking I'm
thinking it's going to be a torture type
of thing like he's trying to lure her in
like he he's not supposed to be there
and she did all the requisite stuff she
had to go to the bathroom and she did
all the requisite stuff uh let me see
your your confirmation so she booked
with Airbnb but he booked with some
other thing called like safe home or
something like that another app so the
apps clashed and overbooked right so
they overlapped so he got there first so
it was just he got there first but we
still thinking that he's a fraud yeah
yeah he he I don't know I kind of
chilled on him at that point because uh
you know when I you know when I went
back in on him like what is when she
came out of the bathroom and he had the
wine bottle so yeah right and just it
gave me some you Vibes some huge
hardcore have you ever seen the show you
yes yes yeah it gave me you Vibes but
not like Joe is actually like he can
blend in being creepy as hell and no one
would know right because he actually you
know obviously he he doesn't give that
like weird energy Vibe but so I'm
sitting there dude and he was like this
and you know he's sitting there staring
at her and she just comes out the shower
because remember she has a she told him
she has a thing with sleeping on you
know sheets so they he did wash the
sheets and he's he's he's he's trying
he's trying to show her like yo look I'm
not the stalker dude like it just
happened this way and he's was like
gentleman enough to you know he said I
was raised the right way yo you could
get the bedroom I'll take the the couch
and it's sounding all good you know what
I thought when he when uh I when she was
like you could take the couch I'm like
don't take that cow I mean you could
take the bed I'm like don't take that
bed the bed is farther away from the
door
I said the same thing I was like I I
wouldn't have did that because because
the bed is is it's it's further away
maybe she felt a little bit more
comfortable because it had a door
looking at his walking mechanism yeah
well that too but okay so she she saw
his his wife
you know what's crazy she never did
anything else with that like well I mean
I guess she couldn't have butthole right
yeah because this is like why would you
take a picture of it when I like my
assumption is like the next day when she
did the job interview she would research
him but it was just like I felt like you
you opened up with that too too much
like you didn't need to do that she
didn't even research him after he told
her exactly who he really was
remember because he told her who he was
and what company he was and they had
like a a very welcome the people in the
chat that hasn't seen this movie they
think they know what this movie's about
so you have no idea buddy that's why I
told Adam because attic has like watched
it halfway I was like please finish it I
said because it's really not what you
think it is and the whole time I'm
thinking it's one way when you told me
that I was there I assumed homegirl was
was the psycho and we were in all the
all the energy was being thrown the dude
and like Midway through you find out
that she's the cycle that's what I
thought when you said that well like
that that movie what was that movie um
yeah it's it's it's like that movie uh
hard candy remember we're in hard candy
they uh Keanu Keanu Reeves invites those
girls over what's it wasn't Keanu Reeves
I think or or somebody that he invited
the girl over and he thought he was is
going to molest or rape or whatever and
she wind up turning the tables on her so
I really like the uh the movie hard
candy but all right so in this joint she
comes out the bathroom and the guy's
sitting at the table and he has the wine
there and the glasses and he's
stammering because he's trying to you
know like break the tension and he's
like yeah you know um I didn't want to
open a bottle of wine because I didn't
want you to see it open and think I did
something to it so I'd rather wait for
you to come out so he literally sat
right there he did everything right he
did everything he did he did I mean hey
here's the question
you think he was trying to get some oh
yeah part of me thinks he was really
pretty though yeah part of me thinks he
was and the other part of me was
thinking he was just being polite like I
don't know I I'm a guy so I'm I'm a
dirty minded dude and if anytime you
introduce alcohol to a woman that you
just meet uh my my thoughts is you're
trying to lay
and but see also that that comes from a
different background maybe he was just
trying to we got to live here together
we you know be called you try to put her
mind at ease because he's supposed to be
this good guy and and she goes to bed
they go to bed right he sleeps on the
couch she goes in the room locks the
door because they did have something and
they didn't lock the door first
she she did remember the first time yeah
the first time she locked the door
that's why it was so creepy when she
woke up and the door was open oh I
didn't know she looked at the first yeah
I didn't catch that so the the dude was
on the couch and he's having a nightmare
and he's like no no no so I'm like oh my
God he's gonna switch into another
personality and he's gonna choke her out
right so I'm thinking go that way either
it didn't she she goes over there she's
standing over him and he touches her and
he I mean she touches him and he freaks
out but at the same time you saw the
basement door you know the basement door
leading down to the basement in the
background you saw it close
so now you know one they're not alone in
the house
he didn't open the door but is he in
cahoots with the people that's inside
the house or the person that's inside
out or something that's inside the house
so I didn't know if it was paranormal I
didn't know if it was a creature I
didn't know if it was a person I didn't
know anything another thing that I kind
of picked up on that was kind of like
useless if you think about it because we
know what happens when she woke him up
like he his demeanor was completely
different like he was rude aggressive so
I think you got to think about it you're
about you're seeing a little bit of like
his true inner self at that time like
that's that's what I thought I thought
he was gonna be a different person like
he he was schizophrenic or something but
think about it this way at it you'll
stand in the house and the girls inside
the room you don't know the chick at all
an Airbnb thing he's a little off guard
too because she told him about the
arrogance of man how if she was yeah
he walks in with no problem yeah and I'm
not saying that doesn't happen but I
ain't never done that so me personally
I'm I'm I'm too wary with things so I
don't know here's my question you king
would you if same scenario would you let
her stay hell no yeah I wouldn't have
either I'll be like you don't got to go
home but you can't stay here there's
just too many
there's you got to protect yourself as a
man sometimes in that kind of scenario
could go into a thousand different areas
and you don't want to put yourself in
that scenario so you should think about
it you in the house randomly a house
that you got airbn first of all why you
got this big ass house be honest with
you in one bedroom one bedroom one
bedroom big house
crazy anyway so you don't count the
bedroom the other bedroom
we're gonna get to that so you got this
you got this place and somebody randomly
knocks at the door and you open it is a
pretty girl first of all and she was
cute she was cute as hell and smart nah
B I don't trust you right off the rip I
scam I'm thinking you set me up I think
once you get me intoxicated or something
dude just coming in and it's gonna be a
Rob scenario or or something worse
something far Sinister so now she would
never get straight A stranger's scenario
where they're like can I use your phone
it's not gonna happen and the light in
the porch is a conveniently unscrewed so
they can't see that face you can't see
who's outside you like oh man
that's why you guys that's why you
invest into ring uh Bell cameras that's
why you know that way you don't even
have to open the door you don't have to
look nothing you just look at that phone
like who you who this
so all right
we got to the next morning and you know
she realizes not that but she has a job
interview that she has to go to and this
guy left the note so that was kind of
weird within itself that he left to know
but he left a note with the key and told
her to put the key back in the box
so that he's able to get inside the
house
she goes on her interview and the
interview is really good and they didn't
even they they kind of explained but
they didn't even really explain what he
was doing there like they went into a
little bit remember no more development
areas but like they went to great detail
what she was doing and he just like was
vague about it like I'm looking at a
wreath but remember when he told her
what company she was from it's like uh
you know on Google right and she's like
oh you know the company is a big tech
company and they were looking for
property in the area and he said I'm
here to scout the properties that's an
area because remember I guess maybe
I guess what I'm referring to is just
like
they went through her perspective and
they just kept him silent you know what
I'm saying like I think that was
intentional yeah because they wanted the
point of view to be on her but my
mindset was like well obviously we know
why they didn't do that with him because
he's kind of been relevant to the story
but yeah exactly so I know he's a dude
from it I know he's the big star of the
film
um
I'm expecting weird things and you know
she goes on the interview and lady's
like yeah so where you staying and she's
like I'm staying over here doneberry and
she's like what why why why what and she
never gave her a chance to finish her
conversation her words and listen guys
anytime you're having a conversation
with somebody let it be a conversation
don't try to dictate it because that
person might have pertinent information
and
knowing now what happens in this movie
that information was vital at that point
she didn't pushed back a lot she did not
push back a lot it's just like nah nah
fam and first off
let's be real here the the chick was
stupid even go back to that place like
when she woke up in the morning and saw
the condition of the neighborhood I
wouldn't have went back I'd have slept
my car at a Walmart parking lot likes no
literally
that was the only place
in probably like a 10 block radius
that was functional
everything else was abandoned buildings
with graffiti written all over them no
cars it was her car was the only car
that even that guy didn't even have a
car did you notice that he didn't have a
car who was Uber and that dude exactly
see so that I'm like that's why I
thought he was strange because when she
got there was no car and then the next
morning well obviously he left already
so it wasn't no car right but later on
in scenario there was never a car so I
don't know how the hell he was getting
from point A to point B but he was
making it there
um so she goes back to the place and she
goes back and it's all in the daytime
she still sees how this place is the
only standing place she goes back there
she gets the key and now curiosity sets
in and she wants to go throughout the
house to check stuff out
and she goes to the basement and when
she goes down into the basement
the door locks by
yeah
slowly closing so I said yeah this is
where the movie starts I said to go get
ass
the first thing I thought is homeboy
down there somewhere like yes I thought
so I'm thinking a Jeffrey Dahmer thing
uh uh Norman Bates thing
and it's
um she's down there for a little bit
she's stuck in there and then she sees a
string and she pulls the string in a
trap door opens so it's a big wall and
it opens and it and it leads to a dark
chamber it's darkening you can't see
what did you think when she opened that
trap door
when she opened that trap door and
looked down I was thinking myself uh
because because originally she kind of
like tempted herself to go in and then
she's like nah ain't doing that no we
ain't yeah and then I was thinking about
stuff well I mean if there's someone in
there
you're screwed you have no way back
upstairs so
oh
yeah she someone in the chat said gas
prices high at it she ain't going
nowhere else nah we're just now so
pretty much what happened after that she
goes into the room
down yeah she puts this mirror down to
put a little bit more light into that
into that dark room because you gotta
look look I gotta be honest with you
guys like this is how it is like I I I
wish I knew how much we could get away
with by showing stuff on YouTube on
movies because it's it's definitely
finished basement like section
no lights
no lights just one light that's pointed
inside the normal room she's at oh you
know I know what I'll do you can do it
I'll bring I'll bring it up on Amazon
Prime but I'll pause on that
particularly it would look like a
picture what do you mean Amazon Prime
you mean uh HBO Max oh HBO Max it is
yeah so so to check it check it out guys
right so check it so she positions the
the the the mirror to look to shine a
light down oh you know she has so much
balls I swear I don't possess those
right so I just I was sat right there I
know I would have broke through that
door I'm getting out of the house I'm
getting out of the house you're not
locking me in the basement I'm getting
out of the house so
as she's going down in a room
there's a R Kelly room
shout out to Frio Kelly
there's a room in the room there's a
bucket
a light
a bed with a soiled messed up mattress
and a camera
or Old school camera could you imagine
the level of horror you see when you
turn that chord you don't know what
you're gonna see when you turn a corner
and see the room but I thought you I
thought he's gonna be behind the door
I thought he was gonna shut the door I
held my breath
right because I'm like oh my God
she she found a situation she bailed the
mouse like oh
I said uh you gotta get out there love
you get love I'm still talking to the
screen I'm like love you got to get out
of there and
she's looking around
and she she's kind of freaked out but
she wants to get out of there and she
runs to the window and and she's banging
on the window
guess who shows up
conveniently
oh but oh we skipped the part where she
the the bum running at her outside yeah
because it and what's funny is I kind of
knew that that was gonna help her in the
future because that seemed real
convenient you know what I'm saying at
her saying hey hey girl hey girl don't
come here girl
she never listens to anybody she never
listens there even a bum I'm like yo man
back up off me B hold on instead give me
six feet this is all I'm gonna show you
guys because obviously we gotta we gotta
protect ourselves but check this out
check this out this is what the place
looked like let me uh let me change this
to a screen cap so pretty much what what
when she opens the things she sees this
and keep in mind
this is something that would scare just
about anyone
terrified me
uh
is it showing it no I don't see nothing
yet but you'll probably see it remember
we're on a little bit ahead to the
Stream
so okay
yeah it still says spoiler all right so
the dude is is is uh outside the dude
who play it Bill Bill's outside right so
I'm like oh snap he's like yo what are
you doing down there right so
she's like
um they like push to win you you I'm
gonna push the window you pull the
window the little window for the
basement and and he and he does it and
she does it and then she's able to slip
from the key so she slips him the key
and he comes and he opens the door and
she runs out she's like yo we gotta get
out of here there's a trap door down
there with a bucket in the bed in the
camera and we gotta go we gotta go and
he's like yo calm down man we can go but
hold on I'm not gonna go off of your
word I want to see what's down there and
he she's like yo what's wrong with you
don't you go down this [ __ ] she's
staying upstairs he's like yo give me 30
seconds
30 seconds I'm gonna go down there and
I'm gonna see then we can leave 30
seconds first of all homeboy I'm gonna
call you I don't owe you anything yeah
you got friends and we not buddies you
could tell that at that point she was
feeling him
yeah she liked them yeah and you could
tell that you know she she generally did
not want that man to be hurt and it's
just like that that that's what screwed
her in the end yo so he goes downstairs
he's downstairs for longer than 30
seconds
so she started calling out his name and
I forgot his name so I'm gonna call
calling him by his real name his real
name is Bill right so he's like Bill
he's like help
and and it's so
you can't hear it like that sounds faint
yeah that you can't like I'd only write
reason I knew that she he was screaming
is because the caption at the bottom was
saying bill was screaming for help like
and it was so low it was so faint but
she can hear it though right she's like
Bill is that
so she goes down the steps but she keeps
she she puts something so the door
doesn't lock because they try to lock
her again yeah so this is all I could
show you guys like this is how this is
how dark it is down there like you could
see like in front of you you there's no
light behind her and that's a long
hallway she's in right now that's how
dark it is like there's only like one
source of light in that entire like cat
I'd call it a catacomb like we didn't
get to that part yet so we still talking
about the one room with the bedroom and
the bucket that's exactly what's up down
there
that's exactly what's up down there so
she has a cell phone so you know we you
know us with technology we got a light
on the joint so she sees the room in the
bucket and stuff but this dude is still
screaming
she goes down there's another room
behind a steel door but you didn't
notice the still during because it was
dark so she opens the door
and it's literally a catacomb with steps
going down un
uh what is it oh we have a super chat
and I I this didn't happen a lot and I
didn't know I actually that you're
bringing it up he says uh as a Sublime
Arc did it I definitely butchering that
I'm not going to try to announce that
because it's just gonna make you look
bad my brothers I love this movie did
y'all pick up on what those phone calls
were about shortly she uh that she kept
ignoring remember she kept ignoring
those phone calls at the beginning of
her boyfriend but that's another plot
hole like it's not like that boy was
going and trying to save her like it's
it's little things like that like doing
that looking at the the ID you know I
would have preferred more to okay keep
going because because I can't say this
or us continuing okay so she sees this
unfinished catacombs the steps that goes
down right so just picture it right
question would you go down them up yo
first
on God man I am back at that I'm not I
wasn't I wasn't going to be there I was
first I would have never been at the
house though
like the key situation didn't go right I
would have saw the outside in the
daytime I would have found out the
borough that I was in like
not gonna happen
I would have drove to the nearest
Walmart and slept in that car before
because keep in mind the reason she
didn't do that is because there was a
huge convention and there wasn't room
for her to go there was no hotels
available that was he told her it was a
huge convention and when he when she
said that to the lady the lady had a
face like really
so I was left to say but she called the
hotel and they said that there were no
rooms okay okay remember when she was
talking to the hotel
I I I skipped up I noted that he said it
was no rooms but the the fact that he
said it was like a convention there I
didn't believe him anyway I'm still
skeptical at this point he was just
trying to keep her there
exactly you got to stay here until my
people show up type of thing I don't
know but he's yelling down in his
basement I'm like how did you get all
the way down there like what what's
wrong with you first of all I'm not
going in there and he's screwing and
he's as loud it's very Audible and he's
screaming out of this dark hole and she
decides to go deeper into the mind she's
frightened every step she takes she's
like her voice is shaking she's like
Keith
yeah and boogers is coming out of nose
and she's like here for you okay please
me okay
I don't I I don't have this level of
concern over somebody I just met but
again she has this level of concern
maybe she thought this was gonna be her
baby daddy I have no idea her future
husband I don't know the guys that she's
supposed to spend her life with me gonna
tell his horrible story to everybody
that they met this is how we meet
no he comes running down the hallway
screaming
don't that way don't go that way come
with me deeper into the hole Hells to
the no like yo we gonna go back this way
they could have potentially got out of
there if she left like immediately when
she caught him like yes
because then with the real movies about
is what happens next like
keep in mind they're fighting they're
fighting in this catacomb about which
way to go
and he's he's terrified his eyes look
scared he's terrified but she's
terrified too but
I'm thinking he's trying to trick her
I'm thinking there's nothing down there
and he's trying to trigger because
remember she walked past room and she
saw cages with bowls in it like they had
dogs or something in it like they had
wow a Livestock in these cages or
something
and she saw that and he come screaming
and you don't know what he's like he's
trying to pull her deeper into the
catacombs and she's like no the way out
is this way and he's trying to pull a
deeper and then the monster shows
it's a barbarian like this thing it's
like deformed from years of incest and
hills have eyes yeah it it literally
squished his head like he's dead now
like he smashed his head up against the
wall I was in shock was you in shock I
at that point I was like okay maybe
maybe I'll keep going like
and then and then it's like
scene
and then you have the dude from Jeepers
Creepers driving in the car
singing a song having a good time and I
and I get automatically hyped because I
see the Jeepers Creepers dude I'm like
that's where I was like oh this is this
this is it I was like this is it this is
the movie right what's funny man is I
didn't like the dude by the end of the
movie well I needed him yo I hate it
because you know in deepest creepers
he's the good guy
he's a nice guy he's a good guy and then
they get him hair
and the the phone call he's having on
the phone is with the HR department and
his lawyer
at the same time
and they're telling them
the movie is not gonna well they did a
pilot for a show and the pilot might go
forward but whatever they do they're not
going to go forward with you
he's like why what happened what's going
on and he's acting he's sounding really
shocked in what's going on and they said
well the your co-actress
uh has some allegations about you it's
like what is the allegations what's up
what's going on and it was like well
and they're telling everybody's telling
them Yo calm down
like really shut up because this line is
being tapped and being recorded type of
thing shut up
like because whatever you expected
against you right
and come to find out the woman
says that he raped her
and it's a moment where he's like no
that didn't happen
I need to talk to her I need to talk to
her we need to clear this up and the
lawyer is like absolutely not he did
whatever you do
not call this woman
stay the hell away from her
absolutely not so
again
he pulls over he's like I gotta let
y'all go and he he sits over at the side
of the road and you're looking at
somebody at the at the height because he
was at the height you got to you just
closed the big deal you're about to make
all his money
the plot twist to this is he's the owner
of that Airbnb
so his financial advisor told him get
your money together because this is
going to be a long litigation the moment
yeah
the moment he was like well what what
we're gonna do is uh he's like well I
own I own property in Michigan it's like
oh I know where they're going with this
I I
when when they started when he started
downsizing and the guy is like well you
know his financial advice is like I'm
not no longer going to be able to carry
you he's like why
nobody wants to be associated with him
right and it comes along later you learn
along later in the film why people don't
want to be associated with him but right
now at this moment at this point right
here
we believe that he's a good guy
right we believe that well you know you
have to he has Reasonable Doubt you know
you got to have you know you're innocent
until proven guilty type of thing and
that's what I felt I felt that right
he's like yeah she was a friend of mine
I'm the one that recommended her for the
movie like what the hell is going on
here so it feels like he was blindsided
so but it's little audio cues on how he
deals with people verbally that he feels
that is beneath him
that allows you a little bit of insight
onto who he truly is like when he was
going to get the car the rental car and
people he's talking to people on the
phone
he's referring to women as the b word
he's uh being condescending to
individuals so
he he gives you a an entitled
aggressive uh narcissistic Vibe he gives
you a Tony broke Tony Stark vibe right
so
he gets two two uh Detroit
he gets to the Airbnb he sees the car
outside he sees somebody luggage inside
so he calls his Representatives that
represents the house one thing we didn't
say is homegirl was not killed by the
Barbarian it was just a dude so you
don't see because it's a team you don't
know what happened yeah you don't see
the death on scene the moment that the
dude from Pennywise was killed it panned
out and that was it for that scene like
it went straight to him driving so like
right there incentivizes she's still
alive because in my in my I I have the
saying in TV and I don't know if you
have the same thing uh uh King nobody no
crime if I don't see a body that's dead
or being killed it never happened
they're alive
well me personally
I thought that you know he she was dead
I thought that she was dead I saw how
brutal the the Watchman call it was
and I thought you thought the movie was
going to be about him getting killed
next like I thought that it was like um
like a pit everybody that goes into the
house something is going to befall them
until like the world yeah
I guess I'm
none of this coming well
I did it I expected him to go down in
the basement and see in one of those
cages
I really did I expected well I wasn't I
wasn't entirely wrong she wasn't in
those stage but so so he gets there
right and he's such a dude you know his
lawyer calls him he's like yo where you
at he goes I'm in Michigan he said what
the hell are you doing over there he
said well I gotta liquidate stuff to get
money because you're not gonna work pro
bono
and he's like why am I not supposed to
he said am I going to get arrested and
his lawyer is like quite possibly
right so that doesn't sound good off the
rip
and then he tells him
um
well let me get all this stuff together
and he calls the office and he's cursing
out his the representative for him that
rents out the airbnbs you know they book
it so he's cursing her out on the phone
and she hangs up and tells him have a
good day have a nice day you know nobody
really wants to go to these properties
so of course double booking and triple
booking uh in that place kind of happens
probably because again it's so rare that
they do get uh somebody to book so he's
like well how come a maid service didn't
come here to clean it up and she was
like well only when and this is the
agent he's talking to on the phone only
when uh a new order comes in on our new
reservation comes in does the cleaning
people come out clean up the place and
then go no one has booked it she hung up
and she hung up she was like no I don't
have nothing to do with this yeah here's
my question
I think that was unprofessional those
people like because he he's asking
genuine questions like genuine but he's
a he's he's an asset this time really I
get that but when the conversation first
started he was just annoyed he's like
look there's people here like you guys
not even checking on these properties
after they've been rented like how do
you not know they've been trashed like
like you re first off How You Gonna rent
to someone when you don't even know the
condition of the house is anymore
this is true but you got to think about
it this way too at it she's like this
guy got one little property and he's
always worrying about this one little
whack property
that's in the butt end of town
it's just you know I personally felt
like you know and you know it's crazy
they call another thing that they
completely
did for no reason they he talked to his
buddy and he pretty much like admitted
to low-key you know doing Shady stuff
and what's funny is like he's talking to
his buddy and I'm thinking myself his
buddy working for the for that chick
like he gonna come back and and then
what he said
it's what he said that let me know
he was a dirty dude and he did uh
actually violate that woman
he said
he's like because his boy he met his boy
at the club for drinks and they're
drinking he gets a little Saucy and his
brother his boy's like yo tell me what's
up man what really happened I want to
hear from you I want to hear from no
magazine I don't want to hear from no
expose I want to hear straight from the
horse's mouth he's like a real talk real
talk you want to hear it you want to
hear it he's like yeah man he's like
well you know At first she didn't want
to but she took a little convincing
first no was no
all right if I tell you no don't you
touch me again that's it right so
and he's like it takes she took a little
convincing but you know I'll put that
child money that she was into it she was
all the way into it after that
yeah because I thought he was gonna kill
her if you she didn't do it exactly
because what he said you know I'm gonna
go get it I had a tiger baby uh-uh
there's no idea I hear the tiger there
so at that point right there I knew that
he was a bad dude so he leaves from
there as soon as he's he's hammered
automatically he comes home he comes
back to the Airbnb he calls the girl on
the phone it apologizes apologizes he
confesses on him oh yeah you know what
you know what I was mad about they never
Revisited that ever again there was no
conversation with the lawyer after that
moment because that's when he started
huh how could they do really because how
the the events happened happened right
after that I get that but why introduce
that in the first place then like yeah
yeah you could have just ended that that
whole lawyer thing with you shouldn't be
going out of town or something you know
what I'm saying like why introduce new
factors into this because you got to
consider that's money they have to spend
uh for for those voice at it like it's
just like I felt like that scene was
useless
it's like you literally brought up new
scenarios because I was expecting a
phone call that was like yo why'd you
call her you know what I'm saying like
yeah like some somebody checking in on
this dude because he's off the rails at
this time
so all right so you know let's let's
let's Advance the story right so he
gives he goes he goes downstairs because
he's checking the square footage of the
place right he's looking at the place
because he's trying to sell a place to
liquidate to get some bread to to start
his defense
and he finds the the trapdoor he finds
the room and he goes in and he sees and
you see this dude is so money hungry he
doesn't see Danger
it's weird like it's completely I don't
see even the most money hungry people I
know wouldn't act like that like because
it's like so strange it was like so keep
in mind guys this dude first off he goes
to the bottom because there's two trap
doors there's one that goes in the
catacombs and one goes to that weird
brim so he sees this bed this this mad
like weird room and I you know I
wouldn't even show it because it's so
like you know what was being done in
this room yeah so no good instead of
being mortified when he see it he's like
how big is it how tall is it like he's
checking he's like okay this is ten by
ten yeah and then he goes on Google and
says is hidden rooms
considered part of of the the square
footage of the house and it said yes
and what's funny is I was thinking
myself
even if these catacombs and stuff was
part of the house I don't think you
could sell it like that anyway because
it right it's probably going into public
domain areas and like it was just weird
because then when he found the second uh
trapdoor he went to the basement this
dude's taking the tape and he's going
down this catacomb uh hallway he's
seeing these these the these uh these
cages and he's like the only thing he
says oh that's weird and then keeps
going down the hallway with the tape
so the measuring takes gets yanked out
his hand and we know what that was so
it's the monster the monster has to be
at least eight foot tall
butt naked it's a butt naked woman
everything's shown by the way
everything's out
and she is running down the horn ah she
can't talk
and it stinks like hell and it's a TV in
there with a baby tape of a woman
breastfeeding a child
and then we get seen
again
so it automatically goes back in time
because there's this guy driving an old
school car and he's driving he goes to
this uh store and he goes inside the
store and he's getting all his baby
supply stuff because uh the woman asked
him what do you need he said I need
diapers I need stuff my wife is about to
give birth and she goes oh you're gonna
take her over to XYZ hospital and he was
like no
um we're gonna be the Midwife and she
was like oh you got a good Midwife and
he was like no it's all me
oh okay and she's like this is normal
yeah you got to think back then that's
completely not normal like that's weird
yeah it was strange so okay she gives
him all the stuff that he's gonna need
for the baby and the videotape the same
video tape that you saw inside that room
so he comes out and he sits in it sits
in his car as he puts his stuff in the
trunk and there's a lady across the way
putting stuff in her car very attractive
lady I might add
and you know something nefarious going
on here now this guy name is Frank
so he pulls up
the lady uh gets out and goes in her
house he pulls up behind
goes in his trunk and pull out a suit
and it says Carlos
and it's for the local electric company
he goes and knocks on the door
he tells the lady that they have outages
in the area
she automatically lets him in the house
see now this time in day and age anytime
uh Con Ed comes to my house I gotta
verify your credentials I gotta verified
they sent you I do it all on my phone
very quickly very easily well this is
back then they didn't have that and they
went on the virtual of others he comes
in a house he checks the water checks
like everything is on here I guess he
was with the local water people whatever
he checks the water the water's running
and opens back from window
which I was just curious like did nobody
not think that she might recheck the
windows before she like goes to bed like
she didn't
well I mean we don't know but clear most
likely what she did well she we do know
because we saw her dress later so when
when that you know when the situation
happens
so all right
scene back to the dude in the hallway
and he's getting thrown into a cage
because he he runs and he goes into the
pit right so he runs and he goes inside
the she uh runs and falls inside the pit
when he falls inside the pit the black
girl is down in the pit
and hold on one second
I'm getting people bothering me when
they know
that I'm on the show yeah so go ahead I
was gonna say like the funny thing about
that whole scenario is
it's just
I'm curious how homegirl lived for two
weeks with that thing
yeah this is three weeks it was two
weeks after that right
they said I think it was three weeks
actually
so now she's in the pit he falls down in
the pit because he had a knife and it um
it cut him he cut it off so with the
knife so he's down there bleeding and
she's like
the monster closes the top
but she sticks her hand in there with a
baby bottle
and she's like yo suck this baby bottle
she doesn't say it
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then the girl she sucks the baby
ball like
she's like hurry up and do it don't you
get up Don't You Buck up on her
and then
she puts it in his mouth and he goes oh
that's disgusting
no he pushes it away
yeah and keep in mind the entire time
the black lady is saying yo put that in
your mouth suck that bottle he's like if
if you flip out she's going to kill you
no so it's nasty it is probably the most
disgusting thing because his hair all
over the bottle nipple
ah
yo he's in a pit he's in a dog pit with
his strange lady he don't know with
somebody forcing a dirty bottle down in
your throat where God knows what
so she grabs him she jumps down there
with him
and she puts her breasts in his mouth
and she grabs him and Yanks him out of
out of the pit yo literally yo it was
crazy because she she climbed up with
one hand and took this full-grown man
out of the pit
homeboys
you take them to the nursery
got the baby on the street and the baby
she's feeding the baby so she wants to
do to him well I like to pay for you on
the screen and she goes Boop I like she
died when you're talking to babies oh I
just love the baby that's a bad potato
right but she's not doing it like that
because she got
foreign
[Laughter]
but it's funny as hell to me but
this guy deserves everything that he's
getting right there this misogynistic
egotistical uh dude that felt that he
could force himself on women the tables
have turned and now this monster is
forcing herself on him and he has to
pretend to be a baby in order to survive
and he doesn't want to play along but at
this time
the the black girl they left the cage
the old the the Abomination never closed
the cage like she she snatched him up
and ran with him yeah and uh get gives
gives her enough time to leave man she
she started what's funny is like
she gets out because she's uh you know
she she's got a good fill of the layout
it looks like at this point it's just
she's never been able to get out so she
she eventually starts to go but she
steps on that that measuring tape and
then it just like the the the Barbarian
whatever you want to call it the monster
here's it and starts running at her and
then you you guys know that the the dude
that was chasing her to the uh the house
that we were talking about earlier like
she tries to go up the stairs but the
door has shut again this door is such an
issue like so I'm thinking something
about the gonna happen but she ends up
breaking the window and the that dude
that chased her into the house helps her
get out and they're like right when
she's about to get a Vibe right when
she's about to be pulled out completely
you see the hands of the creature almost
grab her hand or her feet
but that was that close it was that
close it was so it was so scary because
it's like
and you see her big body in the window
he's like you just got away from me you
know you know we could skip a little bit
uh you know what I liked in this movie
when uh because she eventually is like
look I'm not gonna leave him down there
I'ma go back she gets the cops the cops
don't believe her and what's funny is I
love when they get with the homeless
dude
and he's sitting there he's like
all right
let me say this part let me see this
part real quick okay wait hold on let me
just set it up real quick and then you
can just say this whole part because I
know this part is good for you because
it was great for me all right so she
gets to them she go she she walks to
town she's trying to find people to help
her and it's before his Nightfall right
and she's she's like yo please help um
this man is about to die I've been hell
captive for two weeks and in Detroit
there's a lot of crackheads and stuff
like that apparently well she must look
like a fit the bill is a crackhead they
try to take it back to the place they're
like you don't got any Keys uh whatever
get away from this place and then she
starts to be belligerent to the police
officer and they left and they had to go
on another call
they just left her there and um she
winds up getting inside to go back down
for this dude go at it and and then they
get out of the house and they get to the
water tower with the black guy because
yeah so well it's not uh so they get to
this dude and uh first off keep in mind
that she's hit the creature with a car
uh because she when she got because he
said yo whatever you do don't stay here
after Dark
so she tried to save him and she ends up
running away and she tried to get in the
car because at this point when the cops
ain't listening she's like look I'ma
take my car and go find someone else
which she should have did that from the
start let's be real here like why is she
running around when she could have
gotten her car from the start so that's
kind of unbelievable it is what it is
pothole so ironically the moment she
gets in the car homegirl decides to bust
out the door because he said yo this
creature comes out at night be gone
before the night so she she comes out
the creature comes out home girl runs
her straight over hits the car and they
kind of make you try to feel bad for the
the creature because it's like
so she goes in there and at the same
time the dude that was the that was
being forced to be breastfed he because
she got she went up there to get her he
he's escaped and he's went the other way
instead of the way to the exit and he
came into across the dude that was in
the flashback
and so that dude ended up uh you know
unaliving himself with a gun so he takes
the gun and he goes and he's he's
sitting there he's going real slow
and he shoots the black chick trying to
come and save him
so keep in mind this dude is pathetic
and all his way shapes are formed and
everything always going on and he just
shooting people for no reason because
here's the thing King
maybe maybe I can understand you being a
little bit like
on Trigger Happy
right
but we've seen this big creature first
off you know it's going to make a
different
a different noise you know it's going to
make a different noise so it's just like
I don't understand how you would get the
two confused you know what I'm saying
like me personally I thought
because he didn't have a little light or
something
mm-hmm I thought that was weird
right
because she goes hello wow
that this thing can't talk like that
either
so I'm sorry so what's funny is okay
that she shot so he's carrying her
around because I generally do think that
this dude is one of those people that
he'll mess up and he'll actually feel
bad about it and he tries to fix it but
he is such a coward that any amount of
pressure he'll go right back to his old
ways so he can they get to this this
this homeless dude the dude that saved
her they sit there and she's like look I
know she shot you know we can't go out
there at night she'll get you we'll stay
here till in the morning we'll get her
help then and he's like well how do you
know she's not gonna get me I've lived
here 15 years and she ain't never came
here the moment he says that she breaks
through the back went door the back wall
and kills this man on site
yo so how she kills him I don't care
what anybody say this is probably the
cheesiest thing that could ever be done
she rips his arm off and beats him with
it
homie it's
it's raiding for me that that moment
right there and you know because we we
skipped a huge part in there so for you
guys that's gonna go see it or whatever
you know um it's a it's a real it's
something that happens that y'all really
need to see that's in that middle part
that we skipped all right so and at the
end part uh you know uh she's shot and
they're trying to get away from the
monster while he's she's over there
beating the black guy with his own arm
they go up to the top of the water tower
and you know the douchebag makes an
executive decision because the monster's
right there and he drops the gun oh Mr
fumble fingers now drops the gun and
he grabs the the black girl by her hair
he she was like what are we gonna do
he's like I can escape but you're gonna
have to keep her busy like it throws her
off of the water the the the
whatever it is throws her off yeah a
water tower like what's funny is
the the creature cared more about that
chick that he did yeah because she the
creature with her baby yeah the creature
jumped off after her because he told the
creature go get your baby
and you know what the sad part is he
gets down though thinking they're both
dead and she and the black girl is still
alive he's like oh my God I just I just
panicked I just I just I just go and I'm
at this point dude it's like you know
I'm giving you the benefit for the doubt
through multiple times in this movie
he's like no you you you are a bad dude
you over it's like no because the the
monster
saved her because she grabbed her out of
the air and turned her body around to
take the brunt of the Fall so she fell
on the monster and was still alive and I
thought that was compassion
from the monster because the monster she
was remember she was with her for two to
three weeks right you said and she fed
her this this probably the one that
didn't want to get away or something
like that so you know she she I guess he
had feelings for and I think the monster
kind of knew she could she could live
from that fall yeah I think she probably
knew that because she didn't die uh and
she kills homeboy that's been doing all
this suspect stuff the whole movie
because he gets he picks her up and he's
like oh my God I'm so sorry I'm gonna
get you to help
carry like carries her like half a feet
half a foot and then that and then the
the chicks the the monster is gone she
shows up behind him grabs his uh face
and just rips it in half and then and
then uh the black girl ends up killing
the creature
yeah she has she has to because the the
creature was going to take her back I
kind of thought that the uh
for some reason I thought it was a good
end like a bad way like they were gonna
she was gonna take the creature back uh
she was going to take her she's gonna
take her back yeah
it's it's it's it's it's it leads to
more stuff because it says there's more
stuff there because they said that's not
the only thing that's down there you
know
um because it was a lot of inbreeding
because this guy there might be more of
those down there yeah it's so they might
lead into a friend a franchise to it so
I mean we went on uh a lot about this I
I found it entertaining
um you went uh first last week so I'll
I'll go first this week on giving it my
rating
um I'm gonna give it a rating of three
popcorn uh actually no two popcorn I'm
gonna give a rating of two popcorn
because it's it's it's a super cheesy
super B film I'm gonna give it a rating
of two popcorn and and that's about it
but uh is it something that will give
you a laugh I thought it was going to be
something akin to soar I thought so uh I
thought it was going to be like a
torture film
um
and it and it wasn't uh it was literally
um turned into a comedy when the Jeepers
Creepers dude got there well it was a
comedy for me
but up until then it was a little bit of
a thriller uh a suspenseful film
um so yeah I give it two popcorn but
I'll give it a three uh give it three I
I think it was
it's a here's the thing like it's one of
those things it's kind of like how I
feel about like AAA games you know it's
not a triple A game but it's it's
something fun that I would I would play
if it came in Game Pass you know what
I'm saying I would watch your game uh
it's it's not bad uh I don't think it's
anything special by any means uh like I
said they open up a lot of uh flaws in
the movie that they never really
branched on which I think they could
have did better on uh but I do think it
it's worth a watch as far as that it is
worth the watch I think they could have
expanded a little bit more into the the
origins of the creature maybe that's for
a sequel if they want to do one uh but
but they killed the creatures I don't
know if they would even do that like
maybe you have a scene or two more about
the past you know what I'm saying have
more creatures because remember it was
inbred and this happened over a period
of time you have a bunch of cages down
there so obviously there was more
children because he it and you saw the
the videotape so it was more people that
he kidnapped and and uh you know
um how can you say it aggressively
forced himself upon them uh to to you
know impregnate them so uh yeah it's
honestly it's it's a lot more to the
story and it could tell a better story
because I thought the story was
disjointed in a lot of spaces I thought
it leaned heavily into the the shock
horror uh type of thing uh but again
it could have been better I thought
given the caliber of actors that were
there
a little bit more like the high probably
the highest paid person there like so
fast
I think they should have probably kept
them both alive and then maybe have them
die later on in the movie or something
like that how how do you keep the meal
alive if you're going to introduce
another leading man you know but maybe
have one of those things where they drag
him away and they hear noises like he's
being killed but he shows up like at the
end to help her because he she never
killed him she put him in a different
cage
different ways down the hallway remember
she was scared to go to certain ways too
so I don't know it's it's it's more
stuff that we're gonna see hopefully we
can get a little bit more into this
world and uh I can get it up to at least
uh three and a half popcorns for me or
through the four Packers oh we don't do
have popcorns here
it's either full popcorn so one two
three four five and very really you're
gonna see a five popcorn from us because
you have to earn that baby yeah
we're gonna be doing like the movies and
TV shows I do got one thing I want to
talk about real quick before we head out
go ahead brother Walking Dead has
officially ended
they did yeah yesterday uh the day
before yesterday was the last final
episode of The Walking wow I stopped
watching it right before Egan showed up
with a baseball bat that's actually I
think was the highlight of the show it
was even what was Negan
I'm on season 11 because now since I
know it ended I want to finish it and uh
like that's what I was doing before the
uh for this shows I was watching The
Walking Dead which my voice is going out
for some reason I don't know why but um
well it's because of the coffin I got
the same issue too so a lot of times you
hear me like I try to clean my throat
it's
look is The Walking Dead well did they
drag it out for years yes
but I would never say it's a bad show I
would just say that we aired a fatigue
for zombies in general at this moment
and I would say that The Walking Dead
started it on it's weird that it's been
going on for like
like 11 years
most TV shows never go on this long uh
but it's it's it's it's a good series to
be honest with you but I I definitely
wanted to point that out because I don't
think people people love to hate on The
Walking Dead or just share it's The
Walking Dead
like the best show ever made no uh not
even close but I do think that it
doesn't have too many lows you know what
I'm saying like yeah as far as like
pacing action going on I think it's just
the Walking Dead fatigue speaker not
necessarily a quality of the show
well I think all the spin-offs did it
like you know the fear of The Walking
Dead apparently they're going to do one
with Maggie
so so what are we gonna watch next week
we we got it we got to come up with
something
um I'm watching um
arresting what was it r i p D2 I think
it is oh the different Burn Notice I saw
that on Netflix yeah have you seen the
voyagers on uh on uh Amazon Prime
no what's that yeah watch that there's a
show or it's a movie it's a movie
Voyager the voyagers I think it's a
Prime movie I can't remember all right
so what that's the next assignment I
I've seen voyages watch the voyagers and
in like one or two episodes of Attack on
Titan and we'll go over there all right
well okay I'm gonna watch the attack on
time and get it to episode six and so
all right so guys watch the voyagers
with your girl though because it's a
good movie to watch there's a couple oh
no I I
I may have watched this one with me
then with a shotgun while I go to bed
um now so uh yeah so the Voyages it's on
Amazon and I have to make sure that I'm
inside my camera uh view that's gonna be
fixed uh soon
so you guys listen we got a lot of
things coming a lot of things happening
what I tell people is we gotta just
start you know yeah right now I think
it's the best time to just find out how
we want the [ __ ] uh the show
I don't think we'll break because I
didn't expect us to break that movie
down that much you know what I'm saying
me neither
um that's maybe because there's not like
a whole lot to talk about because like a
lot of the big shows just ended but you
know we got like what
Disney when's the next Disney Plus show
it should be soon I'll I'll check the
schedule we we got Avatar next month yes
there's a lot we can talk about there's
a lot we can talk about um you know
power just ended unfortunately so did
dragon uh House of the Dragons but what
what we'll get to the point where you
know I want to have like
sessions where we talk about the
episodes in detail uh we'll have like
brief going over them all and then we'll
have the spoiler thing come up and then
we'll just start spooling the hell out
of the uh the shows but I do want to
give you guys the opportunity to for us
just to like
like pick the episode apart without
spoiling and then we'll go into spoiler
territory because I want them to
understand that they can watch this you
know without watching the episode to see
if it's like even a movie they want to
watch or an episode or a show they want
to watch but yeah voyagers I think it's
on Amazon Prime I can't remember I'm
pretty sure I'll double check uh it's
it's it's an Amazon exclusive whatever
it's on it's an exclusive to that
platform uh and it's it's a good movie
it is it's a good movie me and uh my
girl watched it uh but this is episode
two
of r r well it's really like episode 10
or 15 but we're not counting those other
ones so this no we're not gonna they're
gonna erase them from the archive
just like we did the first 10 episodes
uh
we dictate what happens here but I talk
to you guys later we'll see you next
week